il ya quelques jours josé publié deux
vidéos ma première vidéo c'était ma
découverte du wep et 40 pro smartphones
qui est là vous expliquer qu'est ce
qu'il en est du point de vue hardware
purement matérielle vous invite donc à
aller voir cette vidéo parce que je vais
pas développer les mêmes points dans
cette vidéo la ici c'est vraiment le
test et je vais vous donner mon retour
sur ce p 40 pro de vidéos sont donc
complémentaires publiées également une
autre vidéo quelques jours après où je
vous présentais la galerie de huawei
parce que oui waouh et là-dessus
fonctionne avec la galerie vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir que depuis l'année
dernière huawei ne peut plus travailler
avec google à cause de l'embargo
américain ce qui fait que vous ne
trouvez plus de plextor dans les
nouveaux smartphones de huawei owen
tranché en faisant le choix en disant
pour quoi qu'il arrive et nous
reviendrait pas en arrière vous allez
donc développer leurs propres et à
l'offre d'applications tina de galeries
et il n'irait plus sur le ps store et je
vous ai donc publié le jour une vidéo
vous parlons de la galerie vous
expliquant comment récupérer les
applications de votre ancien smartphone
sur le nouveau smartphone de huawei
comment récupérer tout votre contenu
comment utiliser la galerie qu'est ce
qu'elle vous proposer je vous montre
également une solution pour trouver des
applications qui ne serait pas sans la
galerie pour pouvoir rendre aux
smartphones vous avez donc aller voir
cette vidéo ce n'est pas déjà le cas
comme ça vous aurez toutes les astuces
néanmoins malgré ça est ce que ce
nouveau smartphone de huawei est bien
est ce qu'il est complet qu'est ce
qu'elle vous propose et quelles sont les
limites j'ai donc pris le temps d'en
faire le tour complètement à 360 degrés
pour vous donner aujourd'hui mon retour
complet et définitif sur ce nouveau et
40 pro 2 oui mais avant toute chose on
est toujours dans le confinement et
pendant la période de confinement je
vous ai dit de m'envoyer vos vidéos de
chez vous savoir comment ça se passait
dans votre maison comment est-ce que
vous réussissiez à travailler comme les
choses se passer en famille en solo et
cetera vous pouvez toujours envoyer
votre vidéo à amour @ monsieur leur
point fr est aujourd'hui on va se
regarder nouvelle vidéo celle de
monsieur greu salut à tous ce petit
moment le confinement au
bout du monde donc à 8000 km on souhaite
bon courage à tout le monde pour ce
confinement en france ici du bout du
monde les règles sont les mêmes boire
plus strictes mais nous avons la chance
d'avoir le soleil et nous pouvons
profiter des espaces des différents
jardins donc mon courage à tous et merci
pour toutes tes vidéos merci à toi de
m'avoir envoyé cette vidéo met on va
faire un tour du côté du pkr un profil
ce que j'utilise depuis quelques jours
je peux déjà vous faire mon retour en
termes de prise en main et nous testons
kyste à carmel plutôt bien dans l'âme en
fait le toit assez facilement sur un
smartphone qui est assez long ça vous
l'aurez remarqué mais malgré tout ils
rentrent très facilement dans une poche
qui a effectivement dépassé légèrement
ça c'est pas extrêmement grave j'aime
beaucoup le travail qu'a fait ou au
niveau des bords arrondis cet écran
incurvé sûr ça vraiment hyper qualitatif
ce que je vais aimer un peu moins mais
c'est normal c'est so 2019 2020 eh bien
c'est la bulle que vous avez là
aujourd'hui techno sont pas encore sur
le marché pour venir intégrer nos
caméras sous l'écran ça ne saurait
tarder d'autre peut pas tenir rigueur à
ce smartphone il ya un vrai beau travail
qui a été fait en termes de design par
huawei que ce soit sur la face avant ou
si on la face arrière personnellement le
blog photos ici ne me dérange absolument
pas de toute façon c'est ce qu'on
retrouve usuellement aujourd'hui sur
tous les smartphones que ce soit carré
au centre où vous voulez que ce soir on
rectangulaire on retrouve cette
hippologie deux blocs photo donc ça ne
pose pas de souci vous pouvez donc être
tranquille en allant sur ce smartphone
vous allez voir un produit qui est
élégant des lignes qui sont bien qu'ils
sont respectés qu'ils restent dans l'adn
de ce qu'on retrouve en 2020 au niveau
des smartphones donc du point de vue
design du point de vue extérieur c'est
un très bon point pour huawei autre très
bon point c'est l'écran va ouvrir fin
très très très bon beau sur cet écran il
est vraiment bien extrêmement lumineux
il ya deux bémols par rapport à ce qu'on
peut retrouver ailleurs ce qui est si
vous avez à l'écran 90's ses taux de
rafraîchissement c'est une autre image
que vous allez avoir par seconde vous
avez 90 hertz et non pas sans risque
comme vous pouvez retrouver sur des
smartphones très haut de gamme en 2020
la différence vous le ressentirez pas
énormément peut-être les gamer les plus
pointilleux mais pour monsieur et madame
tout le monde vous le verrez pas le 90
ans apporte beaucoup de fluidité en
navigation mais également lors des
sciences de gagner le deuxième point ça
va être l'affichage ici vous avez un
écran full hd plus vous n'avez pas de
quad hd une fois de plus c'est un point
de détail pour les personnes les plus
pointilleuses mais quand on arrive sur
les smartphones très haut de gamme et
qu'on décide de mettre beaucoup d'argent
dans des smartphones est bien simple on
rentrait en compte personnellement ça me
dérange pas le fait d'être sûr de full
hd plus au lieu d'un tueur du cul hd et
bien ça vous évitera de consommer coups
de batterie donc il ya un vrai sens du
point de vue de l'autonomie en tant que
je veux dit regretter c'est que vous
pouvez choisir uniquement entre 61 et 90
m si vous n'avez pas de sélection
intelligente ou votre smartphone
dernière basculer automatiquement entre
60 hertz ou 90 est en fonction des
applications fonction des besoins réels
du moment ça vous allez trouver au
niveau de la résolution de l'écran vous
avez une résolution intelligente soit
élevé 2140 par 1200 soit basse 1760 par
800 j'aurais trouvé ça intéressant quand
vous propose également un taux de
rafraîchissement intelligent ça c'était
un truc à venir améliorer plus tard au
niveau des motion rim est là on vient
vraiment s'adresser aux personnes les
plus pointilleuses mais pour moi lorsque
vous allez utiliser votre smartphone
d'aller naviguer vous allez jouer à des
jeux vous allez voir beaucoup d' usage
est bien celle a parfaitement bien 90
heures c'est-à-dire très très bien sans
my heart's ces lieux où mais d'un point
de vue global l'exploit en terme
d'affichage est vraiment bien que ce
soit pour du gaming ça pour du
multimédia on a vraiment ici un très bel
écran points de détails vous avez ici
uniquement un haut parleur mono vous
n'avez pas de haut parleurs stéréo ce
qui fait que lorsque vous venez écouter
la musique leçon viendra uniquement
d'ici et pas du tout dit si ça c'est un
poil dommage puisque vous avez beaucoup
moins d'immersion lorsque vous allez
venir regarder un film une série joue un
jeu sans casque en écoutant uniquement
bien votre haut parleurs si par exemple
vous juin je n'allais pas pouvoir
repérer d'où via le tir pour ça il faut
venir utiliser un casque vous pouvez le
faire bien évidemment grâce au bluetooth
5.15 sera très bien mais ça aurait été
bien qu'un smartphone à ce prix là on
est des haut parleurs stéréo ça c'est un
petit bémol sur la partie multimédia à
côté de ça le fond tel qu'il est la
biosphère la consonne très très bien
vous avez un spectre assez large au son
qui est somme toute assez qualitatif
pour un smartphone question performances
vous n'avez pas le processeur le plus
rapide du marché sans kirin 990 à 8h
processeur 5g le plus rapide du marché
étant le seul un dragon 865 mais malgré
tout pouvait vraiment être tranquille
allait être sans aucun problème il fera
tourner tout jeu tout est très fluide
une fois de plus ça va être vraiment les
utilisateurs les plus
exigeant qu'ils pourront sentir la
différence ni pour le commun des mortels
vous pouvez lire ce smartphone sans
aucun problème il va très bien a tourné
tous vos jeux et prendra parfaitement
bien toutes vos sollicitations vous
tourner ici sur emotion uag 10.1 basé
sur un android 10 emotion ua est
vraiment vraiment améliorée par rapport
à ce que vous aviez avant donc
l'expérience à trouve beaucoup mieux
maintenant la question qui se pose c'est
celle que je vous disais tout à l'heure
sur chaque boîte c'est la question de la
galerie c'est marqué ici puisque
effectivement donnait pas de plextor
toutes les applications google vous
n'aurez pas tout ce qui nécessite les
services de google vous ne les aurais
pas et ça c'est très important et ça il
faut le savoir néanmoins huawei a fait
un boulot qui est vraiment incroyable
pour vous sortir en l'espace de quelques
mois une app galerie qui soit viable en
france et sur ce smartphone là et je
vous parle en français n'est pas qu'en
français mais la langue anglaise ici on
n'en parle pas ici on parle uniquement
dans la langue de molière comme je l'aï
montré dans la vidéo tuto de la galerie
existe plein de solutions pour venir
récupérer votre contenu vos applications
des petits actes ont notamment mis à
utiliser vos services de google via
votre navigateur internet donc ça c'est
vraiment bien mais il ya quelques
applications qui sont toujours un petit
peu réfractaires ce qui fait qu'à
certaines applications que vous ne
pourrez pas malgré tout venir utiliser
là dessus après wade n'est pas magicien
en quelques mois ne sortit quelque chose
qui marche vraiment bien le catalogue
d'applications aux français étant
d'évolution il a encore pas mal de
boulot à faire donc le fait d'acheter ce
smartphone ne dépend pas tant du
hardware parce que je puis vous assurer
que le p 40 pro est vraiment un
excellent smartphone moi je trouve
vraiment temps que je vous montre les
photos vous allez voir cette vous une
petite merveille ils ont vraiment fait
un superbe appareil maintenant la
question ça dépend de vous de votre
profil qui vous êtes et quel usage vous
allez en avoir la question de
l'autonomie est vraiment très très
bonnes c'est un smartphone que vous
pourrez garder jusqu'à deux jours en
fonction ce que vous allez en faire si
vous y allez vraiment intensivement
regarderai une journée sans problème si
vous êtes un peu plus mollo sur un usage
un peu plus raisonnable un jour et demi
jusqu'à deux jours et rassurez-vous vous
avez dans la petite boîte album de
charge de 40 watts qui nous permettra de
recharger extrêmement rapidement donc si
vous êtes allez vraiment faire en terme
d'utilisation et que vous avez très peu
de temps vous le branchez vous le
charger vous repartez et vous êtes
tranquille donc ça c'est aussi très cool
qu'en est il maintenant de la partie
photo parce que c'est un des points
forts de ce smartphone le rendu vraiment
super bon que ce soit lorsque vous allez
beaucoup de lumière ou lorsque vous en
avez beaucoup moins jeunes avaient déjà
montré quelques photos sur la première
vidéo du p 40 pro vidéo vous présenter
maintenant je vous montrais d'autres
photos que j'ai faites vous en ai
sélectionné quelques-unes et vous allez
voir que rendu vraiment bien premières
photos regarder ça la gestion des
contre-jours est vraiment bonne vous à
des biens tout le bleu du ciel vous avez
tous les détails de larmes derrière il
ya un rendu qui est vraiment magnifique
et couleurs sont préservés c'est
vraiment très très très beau la même
avec l'ultra grand angle voyez on a bien
le ciel les nuages rien est cramé on
voit bien tous les détails on va bien
les rayons du soleil là le rendu est
absolument incroyable je viens zoom et
ça fonctionne parfaitement bien quand je
me rapproche un peu plus c'est un peu
moins terrible c'est normal mais malgré
tout c'est quand même pas mal on voit
bien ici tout le veinage de la feuille
on voit bien tous détails et ça c'est
vraiment assez incroyable on continue
sur des roses voyez pareil le détail la
couleur tout est bon la colorimétrie est
un peu différente avec ultra grand-angle
ça c'est aussi normal on se rapproche du
détail c'est parce qu'être plus dalle
mais ça va quand même pas mal on vient
chercher ici avec le zoom on va bien
jusqu'au x 50 la caméra principale
regarder la lune rendu le détail sur le
mur on a des couleurs qui sont quand
même relativement chaude vous avez bien
le bleu du ciel on voit bien les bric
ont à bien toutes les fleurs à côté
c'est pas sursaturé ça fait le boulot
s'arrête pas du tout on passe sur les
ultra grand-angle et on se rapproche
regardez même là là et pourtant vous
avez tous les détails on continue à se
rapprocher pareil le rendu est vraiment
bien et dès qu'on arrive seule fois 50 a
tout de suite beaucoup moins bien mais
malgré tout l'effet waouh est quand même
là gardé ça en plein soleil la gestion
des couleurs la gestion des lumières sur
l'ultra grand temps que ça fonctionne
aussi et vous vous rapprochez pour
récupérer les poils le détail c'est
vraiment pas mal regardez-moi ça là
franchement caméra principale
ultra-grand-angle ouzou mais on a du
détail ont baissé sur notre portrait sur
la caméra arrière ça devient très très
bien des tours et grâce à la caméra
tough c'est vraiment extrêmement bien
maîtrisée et même sur la caméra de celle
fille c'est un poil plus délicat on le
voit ici au niveau des doigts c'est un
peu moins bon niveau de la caméra de
celle ci on le voit également ici bon
c'est du point de détail mais malgré
tout le rendu est quand même bien sûr
mon test en faible luminosité je vous
montre comment s'était fait ça s'est
passé ici toutes lumières éteintes amado
qui parlent les lumières une première
lumière une deuxième lumière on est en
arrière ça on l'éteint ça j'ai une
télécommande pour éteindre la lumière
bleue derrière la fenêtre est située la
haye l'espace est un peu lui la première
photo je les prises juste là comme ça
c'est assez sombre et voilà ce que j'ai
obtenu
la deuxième photo j'ai prises ici
toujours dans la même pièce c'est encore
plus sombre et voilà ce que j'ai obtenu
est la troisième photo j'ai prises ici
il fait quasiment noir et voilà ce que
j'ai obtenu j'aurais tellement aimé me
balader en vie avec les éclairages avec
du monde dans la rue pour vous montrer
qu'elle est le résultat malheureusement
dans période de confinement c'est
strictement impossible mais on voit que
c'est quand même vachement bluffant
parce que ça nous sort un résultat qui
est très bien traîner pour une expo
longue on en plus une très bonne
stabilisation puisque ça marche quand
vous le tenez à la main pas obligé de le
mettre sur un trépied dont huawei
maîtrise sa copie sans la photo nuit on
est ici sur internet qui coûte 1099
euros en pré commande vous pouvez le
trouver un petit peu moins charge vous
avez d'ailleurs un lien en bas dans la
description vous pouvez y aller en
fonction du moment vous allez pouvoir
commander vous allez avoir un tarif plus
bas et en plus vous voyez vous offre une
watch gt2 ça vous permet de mettre un
pied davantage dans l'écosystème lamente
fonctionne avec le smartphone je vous le
dis une fois de plus ce smartphone
technologiquement il est vraiment bien
il est ce qui se fait de mieux du wifi 6
de la 5g dans la question c'est est-ce
que ce smartphone est fait pour vous ou
pas ça dépend de vous et de votre profil
si vous êtes anti google clairement
celui là il est fait pour vous le moteur
de recherche septembre recherche
français qui s'appelle courante donc si
vous n'aimez pas google vous n'utilisez
pas google vous n'aimez pas les services
google vous allez avoir vraiment une
très très belle alternative maintenant
le deuxième point c'est si vous
n'utilisez pas à les services google
mais vous n'avez rien contre google eh
bien vous trouverez aussi là dessus une
très très bonne solution une très bonne
alternative en utilisant les
applications cas dans la galerie où on
ne récupérez vos apps etc a une fois de
plus je vous renvoie ma vidéo sur la
galerie vous saurez tout mais dans le
troisième point si vous êtes vraiment
google a dicté je suis pas persuadé
qu'il soit fait pour vous autant vous
pourrez utiliser les services google via
votre navigateur par contre les
applications ça va pas être possible il
ya plein de choses notamment google maps
vous êtes un petit peu décontenancé donc
là malheureusement ça risque de bloquer
un petit peu d'une manière un peu
globale si vous n'êtes ni pour ni contre
google que vous vous en fichez ça vous
dérange pas utiliser les services via
votre navigateur et que vous êtes un peu
bidouilleurs et bien ce smartphone peut
vraiment été pour vous pour masser
smartphones il est fait pour vous si
vous voulez un smartphone puissant qui
fonctionne bien avec un bel écran et qui
est une tuerie en photo parce que c'est
vraiment un très très bel appareil photo
et qui a une excellente autonomie la
question elle se pose là vous vos usages
vos besoins je peux donc pas vous dire
de façon globale et générale ce
smartphone est fait pour vous ou pas
pour vous vous êtes dessiner le portrait
robot de la personne à qui est destiné
le portrait robot des personnes à qui il
n'est pas destiné moi personnellement ce
qui vous a sauvé du passé du bon temps
avec j'ai fait de très bonnes photos et
je trouve vraiment bien a vous de me
dire et on vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire est-ce qu'il peut
vous tentez se paie car en pro est ce
qu'il vous plaît est ce que vous
pourriez lâcheté est ce que vous l'avez
commandés s'est pas déjà le cas que
voulait le faire j'ai mis le lien bien
évidemment juste en vain description sur
ce je vous embrasse vous rendez vous dès
demain vous invite à vous abonner s'est
pas déjà le cas vous allez petit bout
d'os qui est juste là et on se retrouve
demain il va continuer à parler de teck
allée des bisous et à demain ciao ciao
[Applaudissements]
jean
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]